Conan here, reminding you all
to check out our new
Esports show "Wreck League,"
where we force professional gamers
to compete in video games
that are quite absurd.
Hosted by comedians Orlando
Leyba and Forrest Shaw,
this week's episode pits pro gamers,
MissesMae and StoneMountain64,
you can tell I'm a fan,
against each other in the brutal
and unforgiving world of "Goat Simulator."
That's right, we're forcing
these two pro gamers
to see who can be better
at controlling a fake video game goat.
Anyway, I think we
finally reached the peak
of sports entertainment.
"Wreck League" airs this
Friday night at midnight
as part of the TBS show "Super Punch."
Can't wait to see how many cars get licked
by a simulated goat.
Check it out.
Round two,
(intense music)
find Conan O'Brien and headbutt him.
The first one of you to do
that will win round two.
Where would Conan be?
I think that I'm within the
vicinity of Sir Conan here.
Conan, where are you at?
Where are you at, my guy?
Oh wait. What the, oh!
(goat screeching)
This studio is mine. You
gotta bring me on the show.
I won't make this big of a mess,
but no promises either.
(crowd cheering)